la contagion de la peur plus rapide que
celle de la maladie avant le coc vite 19
des pandémies en provoquer des flambées
d'angoissant france
à tort ou à raison 1968 la grippe de
hong kong 1 million de morts dans le
monde dont 25 mille en france
cette pandémie mondiale al'inverse
ducobu 19 est passé sous les radars
médiatiques français elle n'a pour
autant pas manqué d'inquiéter la
population
la preuve le centre anti grippe de
l'institut pasteur croule sous les
appels en 1968 car les vaccins tarder à
arriver
[Musique]
1996 la vache folle
cette crise sanitaire due à la
consommation de viande atteinte d'un
syndrome a fait 224 morts dont 25 en
france
la population se méfie la consommation
de boeuf a diminué de 10% pendant la
durée de la crise
la preuve pour la première fois depuis
longtemps française
en soi ce qu'ils entendent depuis deux
jours 2003 le strass en coronavirus
similaire au qu'ovide 19 lui aussi
partie de chine 774 morts dans le monde
comme aujourd'hui dès l'apparition de la
maladie avant même qu'elle ne se déclare
sur notre territoire un sentiment de
méfiance à l'égard des asiatiques vivant
en france grandit alors même que ces
personnes n'ont pas de contact avec leur
pays d'origine
dans ce restaurant en 2003 on prend la
chose avec le sourire
mais quand même personnage et
généralisée au pollen leur bloc à chaque
fois qu'ils ternissent j'ai regardé ça
fait rigoler c'est sûr il y eut ensuite
eu la grippe aviaire puis la grippe 1 et
à chaque pandémie au risque d'épidémie
une part de craintes légitimes
une autre part de peurs irrationnelles
[Musique]